smoke rises over the northern Syrian
town of Rasul ain the Turkish Defense
Ministry declared victory over the
Kurdish SDF forces for a second time
here on Monday Kurdish fighters have put
up fierce resistance and these are
Syrian soldiers in the town of tel otama
just a few kilometers away after a deal
was made between the SDF and the Syrian
government state media said the army
would confront Turkish aggression the
Turkish president remained defiant we
are not going to enter manbij the real
owners of that area are our Arabic
brothers and they are going to enter
that area our approach to this is that
they are going to enter there and we are
going to make it secure for them the
Syrian Kurds have made deals with
Damascus before especially in the battle
against ISIL but an SDF commander said
they were faced with a difficult choice
this time there is little trust between
the two sides but the SDF quickly
suffered significant losses during
battles with Turkish forces in their
Syrian or rebel allies it's an important
deal because the Kurds and the Assad
regime and Damascus
both have the same enemies they have
turkey as their enemy number one and the
Islamist rebel groups as their enemy
number two this is a long-standing you
know in a sense I wouldn't say
partnership but it's an uneasy
partnership that they've had Damascus
cannot rule Northeast Syria without the
Kurds turkey says this military campaign
is targeting the SD s main Kurdish
fighting force which it says is aligned
with the outlawed Kurdistan Workers
Party or PKK which has been fighting the
Turkish government for decades turkey
says it wants to set up a safe haven for
refugees to return to in northern Syria
but the UN says around half a million
people could be forced from their homes
if the violence doesn't stop US defense
secretary mark Esper says a deal with
the SDF and damascus meant having US
forces stuck between the syrian and
Turkey
armies was untenable the Syrian army has
moved north to potentially confront
Turkish forces at various points close
to the border the SDF hoped that by
teaming up with the Syrian military they
can force Turkish forces to retreat but
at this stage that seems highly unlikely
despite the threat of potential
sanctions from some European countries
and the US president orowan says he has
a plan for northern Syria and no amount
of threats are going to stop him from
achieving his goal
Charles trafford al Jazeera close to the
turkish-syrian border